all right darcy hello darcy
uh where you from where you where'd you
grow up i grew up in the midwest um i'm
from milwaukee wisconsin which if you're
not familiar with that nearest big city
would be chicago
and i'm now kind of out in the suburbs
in the greater los angeles area you've
been here since since how long uh 2014 i
moved to california okay yeah was your
childhood like
my childhood was
a
dysfunctional but normal
i don't think that most people have
super happy childhoods so
middle class upbringing uh mostly was
raised by a single father both of my
parents had substance abuse issues
but nothing
nothing extremely chaotic um
you know especially
compared to you know some things that
other people
may have gone through but
you know
it was a morose morose child i would say
made it through high school
yeah of course i have a graduate degree
oh you do yeah
in what
i am a literacy specialist oh great yeah
you've had jobs
i've had jobs yeah yes
i mean i guess when i say jobs i mean
more like
straight jobs not not sex related jobs
none of my jobs are sex related as a
minor side hustle i do some fetish work
in
the aspect of of hosting events at a
private dungeon and doing fetish
performances that's more your personal
that's my personal life it's a very
small portion of my income in my
you know day-to-day life i have a
you know professional normal salary
career i have you know like i said i
have a degree master's degree i just
want to establish that you're not yes
i'm a normal working
professional person i have a have a
career have a home
uh
with you back to your personal life you
you would describe yourself as what your
your so in the um bdsm community
uh there's you know kind of a spectrum
from being a submissive to a dominant
right in the middle is a switch
i'm a switch
who mostly is more on the submissive end
of things and what that looks like in
terms of
uh what i do and how i play my main
fetish would be masochism which is
receiving pain in
many different types of fun and exciting
ways
and you're you're into this you're not
doing anyone's a favor when you're doing
this you're oh no it's very much for me
it's very much for me
um there it's not
even within this community where people
like to play this way
at more moderate levels
finding people who are skilled enough
and comfortable enough
to
inflict to inflict pain at the level
that i enjoy is not easy and it requires
uh quite a bit of
mutual trust
um on on both ends so yeah it's it's not
super common to find anyone who is an
extreme sadist or an extreme masochist
there's a lot of people more in the
middle
who do the play more
as a role play versus really getting
heavy the way the way that i enjoy doing
yeah is this something you've always
enjoyed or something you discovered
later on in life um so my interest in
bdsm in general
um
it came onto my radar in my early 20s
i'm about to be 35 so
i'm not
old or young i guess and um so in my
early 20s
i you know somehow just kind of became
aware that this was a thing that people
did
and it seemed really appealing to me and
i wasn't in a relationship at that time
where
it was an option to explore it so i
didn't really start actually doing it
until i was about 27
and i had a partner that
was also new to it
and we
you know kind of gradually started
exploring it together and then over the
years
um and it was you know somewhat of a
gradual process
i um was able to
push my limits more and more and more
with the intensity of the type of of
things that i was doing
and also moving to california gave me
the opportunity to get involved in like
the organized bdsm community there's
commercial dungeons there's a lot of
events
social gatherings and things that um
just gave me a lot greater access to
a community of people who are who are
involved in doing the stuff that i like
to do so that kind of ramped it up a lot
as well so probably by the time i was
if i started getting into it at 27
probably by the time i was 29 i was at a
very high intensity level and had you
had
vanilla relationships before that
yeah i have i haven't since
the one that i was in from like age 22
to 27 was the last vanilla relationship
i've been in and also the last
monogamous relationship i've been in and
i don't um
have those kinds of relationships either
vanilla or monogamous anymore neither of
those really
are compatible to my needs and wants and
desires so you're much happier now much
happier now more fulfilled yeah the only
exception would be since i am
non-monogamous is if i have a
a casual relationship with a vanilla
person
um you know once in a while as long as
they're kind of accepting of what i do
and they're comfortable seeing my body
look the way that it looks a lot of the
time because i do have a lot of either
bruises or cuts or permanent scars even
um
you know
i'll have those types of interactions
but that would never be like
my primary relationship right now my my
primary relationship um
with my very serious romantic partner is
a a dom sub relationship where i'm a
24 7 submissive to him so beyond just
the way that we play together
the dominance and submission is also
integral to our interpersonal dynamic
and the way that we structure our
relationship how
how intensely do you guys take these two
roles
personally i don't want to get too noisy
about your personal life oh no get knows
i mean that's why we're here it knows
about my personal life um so there are
uh parts of my life i mean it looks like
you've been abused yeah no he didn't do
this though i had other friends do this
i mean he and i play but um
all of this was from other other people
who i play with
um a lot of my play is non-sexual so i
have a lot of friends who i play with
that i'm neither sexually or
romantically involved with and that's
kind of where most of this came from um
in this particular yeah
you want to show us some of the uh
absolutely abuse that you sure recently
um so let's see i'm trying to think of
how to do this appropriately
so this is all mostly from caning some
paddling and then
a type of toy called a dragon tail
and the one that we used this past
weekend was actually
a real dragon tail in that it was made
from a piece of
leather that came from a crocodile's
tail
wow um
i broke the cane that we were using
that's happened to me several times
so it was
uh being used so aggressively on my body
that it snaps you also have a bunch of
scars across your chest yeah i want to
show those as well but i want to make
sure i'm like not showing my nipple
and getting you in trouble with youtube
um so these are from a much smaller cane
it's a type of tool some of these are
from a type of tool called a say the
stick which is
like a tiny little metal rod that you
pull back and almost twang like uh
what's that instrument called
the little harp you pull it back like
that
um and then some from a riding crop
um the same kind that you would see in a
horse show it looks painful
it is painful yeah so
all of that stuff is from various
different types of implements and then i
don't have any markings right now from
um
any bloodletting uh but i do a lot of
that as well so i'm sure you were
bleeding from some of this right yeah
the marks on my behind uh did break the
skin in several places yes yeah
and and how often will you will you
indulge in this
so i play
at some
level um probably at least once a week
every time that i do have sex it's
almost always um state of masochistic in
nature to some extent but it does extend
also quite a bit beyond my sex life and
a lot of my play is non-sexual the level
of intensity that it took for me to get
as as married as i am right now that's
something that maybe
happens every every couple once every
couple of months um
yeah you can't do this too often you
can't do it too often and also um
something that happens with people who
are heavy players like i am over the
years
is your body goes through a
leathering process
so basically i don't really bruise as
easily as i did
you know a few years ago
the type of scene that i had even you
know i know the bruises on me right now
look pretty impressive had i played at
that level
five years ago
i would be black from knee to i mean i
would just be solid black on my whole
butt so your body is tough and down my
body has toughened up there and if you
look really closely at my butt what
you're not going to do there's areas
that have some kind of permanent
discoloration and those areas no longer
bruise
yeah
and again this is something you you
enjoy you oh yeah you like it it's so
good
do you think it's
stemming from something in your
childhood
i don't were you spanked as a child or
anything like that no no and um
i don't think so and if you talk to
people you know who have these kinds of
fetishes or people in the pdf's on
lifestyle a lot of people have different
hypotheses about
what the
psychological origin of their interests
are and i
come from a world view where i don't
really
feel a need to pathologize
myself in any way i don't have the
expertise expertise
or background in psychology to do it
anyway so even if i was to speculate
it's not that i really would know what i
was talking about um i didn't experience
any sort of abuse physical abuse or
anything uh in my past so i don't see a
correlation there
um
it is a mental health coping
thing insofar as any positive thing in
your life would be so like for example i
also do yoga i also draw i you know
pretty much any positive thing that you
do in your life that helps you
construct a satisfying and fulfilling
life and is good for your mental health
i guess it's a coping mechanism the same
way those things are but i wouldn't um
[Music]
really
dig into the psychology of it any more
than that you know i just don't i feel
like that's kind of staying
going out of my lane of expertise anyway
and before some viewer watches this this
interview and says
oh this woman's a freak she's demented
yeah whatever yeah you you're happy
you're healthy you're so happy
yeah yeah you just use this this is your
little kink
this is my kink uh beyond my kink it's i
mean it is my lifestyle so it's more
bdsm in general is more than just a
fetish for me is a lot of my personal
life and social life revolves around
this as i mentioned i'm pretty active in
the the organized bdsm community
um
and
a lot of my interpersonal relationships
ha both you know platonic friendships
and my my two main romantic
relationships
uh all involve this
so it's more than just a kink
but it definitely makes me happy it's
definitely
something that
brings me a lot of joy and a lot of
satisfaction and feels very
natural and the more and more that i
grow into it and
[Music]
kind of develop my own expertise in it
um and
and and develop my own interests the
more i'm finding things that i enjoy you
know
and there's a neurotic
you know benefit for you as well right
yeah so it's like you know venn diagram
is the circles with the where they meet
in the middle so there's like you know
sex and there's like the santa masochism
and there's a lot of overlap in the
middle
um
but i do engage in a lot of say
domesticism that is not sexual so a lot
of it is just for its own sake
you know i could do a scene where i'm
just getting beat up by a friend of mine
and we're not dating we're not involved
sexually whatsoever and that's i have a
couple of very close personal friends
who
have been play partners of mine for many
years and i've never uh
you know been sexually and or
romantically involved with them at all
but with my sex partners almost always
yes all myself and your sadist partner
during these of these
uh get-togethers are
is it a frightening experience dealing
with somebody like that or is he kind of
smiling and laughing and you guys are
snickering while this is going on
how serious does it get uh i i laugh a
lot i'm i kind of almost laugh
maniacally when i'm in pain
so most of the time
the dynamic is playful most of the time
the dynamic is playful even at a very
high intensity level
um the only time when it gets
frightening and i do really love when it
gets frightening it's not easy to
accomplish that um especially when you
are accustomed to to doing this it takes
a lot to become frightening
um if i do
a consensual non-consent type of of sex
so rape play sexually
uh explain that please that's
that'll be interesting
right
you're kind of simulating you are you
are consensually simulating a rape yes
um that can get frightening and that
really only works when it's frightening
it doesn't there's it doesn't feel
authentic if it if it doesn't get to the
point of being frightening um so
something like that needs to be
negotiated explicitly ahead of time
obviously again trust
between both people it's not something
you do with someone on a first date it's
gonna be a very special practitioner uh
yeah yeah it's it's not it's not an
early interrelationship activity but um
yeah that can get to an intensely level
that there's genuine fear um the the
impact play you know getting beaten up
um especially if there is
different types types of bondage
involved i enjoy a type of bondage that
people would call predicament bondage
where
it's exactly what it sounds like you're
in a predicament so there's something
about it where
if you try to escape it gets worse or if
you don't follow instructions it gets
worse
so it's not just being tied up it might
be
that you're there's a lot of different
ways to accomplish it but something like
that can elicit genuine fear and and if
i do on those you know more rare kind of
special treat occasions take the pain
play the impact play
um
to a really highly intense level there
can be some genuine fear genuine tears
and that's um
a really uniquely cathartic
experience that that is very very
satisfying afterwards
um
but yeah most of the time an average
scene it's a lot a lot laughter a lot of
fun
and it relieves some tension or
something after yeah i mean this is
did you is there some kind of release
yeah definitely i mean you know the same
way that like getting [ __ ] really good
has a release or like
running a marathon has some release yeah
yeah the the um
endorphin physical reaction of the body
to going through a really intense
physical inspiration yeah i'm sure
there's all sorts of like dopamine stuff
you know again i'm not going to like
speak to
uh neuroscience in a way that i don't
have expertise or physiology in a way
that i don't have expertise but there's
definitely
a physiological
release to it and a mental release to it
absolutely and in larger cities like los
angeles you
you'll have a community of people that
are into this a large community right
there's yeah there's a very robust
community in l.a there is
um there are several commercial dungeons
uh the event that i just went to last
week uh this past weekend is called dom
con it's the biggest
bdsm convention
you know in the country and they do it
in la they also do it in new orleans
it's hosted by
the same you know group
and people come from all over the
country
you know so this area um if you are
local to la it's a good place to be
kinky definitely more so than the
midwest when i was in the midwest i
didn't really have access to a community
i know there was more going on in
chicago
uh but i didn't get involved in the
kingston chicago is a little bit far
away from where i grew up
and everyone in that community kind of
understands that everyone's got their
particular kink and they kind of respect
each other and
i mean yeah
to the extent that um
there are social norms and etiquette yes
but you know there's definitely
shitty people in any community
um and there's a lot of different facets
of the king community so there's a lot
of things that like a lot of people love
that i don't do there's a lot of things
that i do
that people find shocking um
even within the community
yeah what's the most extreme your abuse
has gotten
uh it depends on what you think of as
extreme so
you know the intensity of beatings that
i do with um you know like i said impact
play could be hitting
basically hitting with any type of tool
or bare hand or foot punching kicking
knees
uh canes paddles whips blah blah blah
any of that would be under the umbrella
of impact play i take that to a high
intensity level um i like playing with
wax i like playing with fire one of my
favorite favorite favorite things is
knives and needles and when i use
knives and needles
a lot of people use those things more
performatively where it's like you're
etching the surface but you're not
really drawing blood like i've been
stabbed i do pretty extreme bloodletting
yeah
and you you see this as just something
that you're just into you're not
so uh yeah unless i'm doing this it's
not it's not like cutting like something
no no not at all which as a you know
millennial who was a goth teenager in
the early 2000s i've done that also it's
very different
um very different you know cutting
from what i remember you know 20 years
ago whenever i
you know
had done that
was
not something that felt particularly
good it you know may have had some
catharsis and certainly you know in
hindsight
was probably a much healthier coping
mechanism for mental health stuff than
you know
i don't know doing drugs or something
um there's certainly worse things you
could choose to do
um but it wasn't for
[Music]
pleasure
um when i do it now number one it's
usually with other people not always um
it's usually with other people so
there's uh
an interpersonal aspect of it and it's
you know very much for pleasure unless
i'm performing
if i'm constructing a performance which
almost always my performances are based
around the needles
and blood play more so than impact play
[Music]
you know i might choose to do things in
a way that's more flashy than i would if
i was just playing in you know in my
personal life but it's still pleasurable
so has your life
gone into an area where
being a mother
having a vanilla relationship
raising a family all that is is kind of
out of the picture
i don't have children yeah but you still
could
i don't plan to
um and that doesn't have anything to do
with this aspect of my life i know
plenty of people who are married who
have children have families that are in
this community
monogamous or or not
and do so successfully one of my very
very dearest friends is in
a master slave relationship and his uh
slave is married and her marriage is
vanilla marriage
and they're all you know in this
polyamorous relationship that's a very
wonderful loving relationship for
everyone involved and she you know
so um people can absolutely do that
successfully i don't have children nor
do i want to
um and i don't have any vanilla
relationships nor do i want to but i do
have you know like i said a primary
romantic relationship a serious romantic
relationship that's very fulfilling
and um then i also have another romantic
relationship which
is also very loving and fulfilling
although the commitment is is different
in nature it's not as committed do you
think humans are meant to be monogamous
or are meant to not be monogamous
or does it just depend on the person i
think
culturally
and socially it absolutely depends on
the person and there are individuals who
might be happier being monogamous
and there are individuals who might be
successful being monogamous
my understanding of uh evolutionary
biology which is something i have
a little bit of an armchair
understanding of it's i'm interested in
i've taught taught bio before
my understanding of human evolutionary
biology is that
we did not evolve to be monogamous
there's a really good book called sex at
dawn
that is written to be really
entertaining and accessible it's like
about evolutionary biology but it's like
a very much like
kind of comic
not very academic language type of
explanation of it so that you know
that's a good good book that talks about
it but
um there's some characteristics of of
humans that kind of indicate that
you know we didn't evolve that way and
didn't really start being monogamous
until
more like around the agricultural
revolution when we started having
permanent
living um
you know
communities and that's sort of when
monogamy came into the mix and over the
course of 300 000 years of human history
what's that only like 10 15 000 years so
most of the time we were not
do you find the limits or the uh
the lines you won't cross change as you
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah two years ago i
had a hard limit like you cannot piss on
my face now i will drink it out of a
wine glass
like
i don't think
five years ago i would have seen myself
doing bloodletting and now it's one of
my favorite things um
i i have aspirations i haven't done this
yet to do a hook suspension i'd like to
do that sometime soon and uh
even when i was getting into this
community years ago i don't think that
uh if you would have asked me if that
was something i would do i've been like
maybe not it might be a little bit too
much you know but now i'm like
yeah i want to [ __ ] do that
[Laughter]
you're not hurting anybody
i'm hurting myself you're hurting
yourself in a good way
it's all pleasure very much so
very much so
it's very interesting yeah i mean i like
having the opportunity to talk about
like how much i [ __ ] love this and
how
fulfilling and satisfying and positive
it is for me do you think most americans
are uptight about sex and they just are
not open to
even exploring
this i think a lot of people don't even
know what options are out there for them
they want to entertain entertain these
ideas even it's they don't even i mean
they don't even know that the ideas are
there to entertain or
have such a foundational
misunderstanding of it that
if they did want to approach it they're
approaching it from
you know
not not the right perspective certainly
like i've never like read or seen the 50
shade stuff but i know that that kind of
brought this into the
media and um
there's probably a reason that was a
popular book
right but everyone in my community was
really upset about it because like i
said i haven't read or seen the movie
read the book or seen the movie but my
understanding of it is that it really um
[Music]
kind of pathologized it or just like
didn't didn't represent it well or
fairly or positively
um
[Music]
but yeah i think you know
like with monogamy again for example
it's the default setting people don't
know that there's another option
or even if they do
their perspective of that other option
is like oh well that's like a [ __ ] up
weird thing to do you know
um and it's just reframing
how you see things um
and and trying to
maybe relearn
what your values are because like a lot
of people think of monogamy or think of
even you know
as being a moral
value that you should have well why what
about that is moral
i i don't have any philosophical or
moral attachment to monogamy which is
why i don't choose to do it
um the same thing with kink people might
assume that it's unhealthy well why what
about it
is unhealthy what
you know cultural
background do you have that's sort of
given you that implicit bias to make
that assumption and
if you know you have that assumption can
you reframe the way you look at it
so um
you know i think i think more people
would enjoy a lot more
things and have a wider repertoire
of um
experiences if they even knew that these
things were out there
and available to them and they and they
just don't
yeah i don't know if that makes sense
yeah it does no what what would you what
would you say is the most important
thing you've learned from this
being this
in this lifestyle the most important
thing i've learned
from this lifestyle is
100 communication the communication
skills that you have to have to
engage in the things that i engage in
um
are
far beyond what most people ever develop
and highly nuanced and it takes a lot of
um emotional maturity it takes a lot of
self-awareness
in order to do it well there are people
out there who do it poorly
but i think that overall the
relationships that i've had um since
i've been doing this um
in all aspects of the relationships
have been healthier
because of the
ways in which you really need to
communicate in order to do this
successfully
and the ways in which you need to be
supportive and develop trust with people
in order to do this successfully so
again it's like you know there's always
people who have bad relationships
there's always toxic people i'm not
saying everyone in the
kink world is uh
you know a wonderful amazing person but
i definitely think that um
[Music]
the communication skills that i have
from this um
are are well beyond what i ever would
have needed or had the opportunity to
develop had i not you know entered into
this type of life
you know it's great yeah
all right dassey thank you so much for
you're welcome thank you for having me
opening our minds a little bit yeah and
i wish you the best of luck hope you
heal quickly i hope so too so then i can
do this more
thank you
you